on a frigid morning in New York City
dozens of migrants have been waiting in
line for hours for an opportunity to
apply for Asylum at the local
immigration office you want to use the
bathroom go to the park across town at a
migrant shelter hundreds of others
mostly from Africa and Latin America
line up as well some have been waiting
for more than 7 hours in 3° C
temperatures they're all looking for a
bed to
sleep somebody call police somebody call
the police you been trying to get in
here all day you can't do that
frustrated tempers sometimes flare but
all they are seeking is a better life in
America I'm just trying to get my you
know life good because you want to be
like everybody else in New York to pay
taxes and stuff you know more than
150,000 Asylum Seekers have arrived in
New York City since the spring of
2022 many of them bust to new New York
from Texas on the order of its Governor
Greg Abbott New York City officials say
they can't take any more Asylum Seekers
and point to scenes like this last
August when migrants were forced to
sleep on the sidewalk because there were
not enough beds in the
shelters in order to avoid more chaotic
scenes like that last month New York
City's mayor Eric Adams announced an
emergency executive order acquiring all
private bus companies to give the city
32 hours advanced notice before dropping
off migrants in the city but City
officials say not a single bus company
has complied so the mayor has announced
a lawsuit against those bus companies
seeking more than 700 million in Damages
there is some elected officials like
Governor Abbott of Texas who's using
individuals as political pwns and then
others who are sort of just turning a
blind eye or trying to play a game of
one-upsmanship in this moment um and
forgetting that there are people in the
middle of all this for now migrants
arriving in New York City are more times
than not finding themselves out in the
cold waiting for the help they need to
support themselves Gabriel oando Al jaaz
New
York make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
zero